[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MARK THOMPSON: Thank
you so much, thank you.
Thank you, David.
And for those of you
who don't know David,
David is really one of the
pioneers of executive coaching,
really one of the people
who I think have written
so thoughtfully in inspiring
ways about where we
can find a life that matters.
And that's what's so terrific
to have an opportunity
to talk with all of you
about today here s Google.
I feel like I've been in a
Google office every week.
I was just in Singapore
and London and New York,
and I'm on my way to "Joburg."
I mean, this is the front
desk at "Joburg" Google.
It's howzit!
[INAUDIBLE]
And so I feel so welcome
when I come here.
And I love coming to Google,
because it's a particularly
poignant time for me, because
I started on a passion play
about 20 years ago, where I
was in a late night nightcap,
I'll admit.
It was 1:00 o'clock
in the morning.
We were in Switzerland.
And we were jet
lagged and exhausted,
and I was talking to a
couple of famous Googlers.
It was Larry and Sergey.
They were at the
World Economic Forum.
And we were all just
gushing about having
met someone iconic in
our lives that we never
thought we would meet.
It was one of his last
public appearances.
It was Nelson
Mandela, and we were
thinking about how this
guy should have been
the most angry man in Africa.
And what did he
do with his life?
He decided to reinvent a life
that mattered for millions
in rethinking the way
that he could have impact
and a sense of
belonging for a culture,
and that set me on a path that
would be life-changing for me.
I had been building
businesses most of my career
as an entrepreneur,
and I decided
that I wanted to pursue
this question of how
to create a life that mattered.
Could we find the DNA?
Could we find some
ingredients by interviewing
enough successful,
high-achieving people
around the planet, and could we
unlock some of those secrets?
Please come and sit down.
I'm loving the opportunity,
also, to be on live streaming.
And for those of you who did
get books and didn't get books,
I'll make sure that
you get free copies,
so just ping me through
the Google Network.
And for those that I
might see in other cities,
please let me know
if you're interested.
I'd love to share with
you all of the research
that we learn about how to
create a life that matters.
And so here's where I
want to go with that.
I want to start with
just a little piece
of archival footage,
here, of just the first 60
seconds of the first interview
we did starting in 1998.
And I'm going to bring
you to present, and then
share with you 8 of the
principles out of the 36
that we learned.
And the eight that I
picked is because they
are the most, I think,
hidden from our souls
and from the public.
They are the ones that
aren't talked about,
the ones that have
the biggest impact.
And let me share with
you Herb Kelleher, kind
of a famously happy
guy, who seems
to have created a life that
matters even though he's really
just running a discount airline.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Anything?
- To tell you the truth,
I realized [INAUDIBLE]..
And they said, we can't have you
handle anything that's really
meaningful, but we like you.
So what job are we going to
give you where you don't really
have to do anything meaningful.
And you can't really
screw up the company,
[INAUDIBLE] chairman,
president, ceo.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
MARK THOMPSON: Hey, how are you?
So it was amazing to be able
to meet people like Herb who,
in a sadly unusual way--
when you meet CEOs,
aren't necessarily
the most happy people.
And when you talk
to him, you could
see how that filters
through the organization.
How many of you have ever
been on Southwest Airlines?
Of course, yeah, we've
all had to do that.
I was coming here on
Southwest Airlines,
and I had the typical safety
talk that you get on Southwest.
Now, these people can't
be paid all that much--
not in money, at least.
But why is it that they're
just a little happier,
a little bit more engaged,
maybe a little insane--
have you noticed this?
We're rolling out on the
runway, and the flight attendant
was giving us the safety talk.
Nobody's listening.
We're all reading our devices.
He starts to
pretend to be angry.
He says, guys, if this
plane falls out of the sky,
would you like to know
the documentation?
You can hear the thud.
People are dropping everything.
What's this guy up to?
He says, OK, here's
what's going to happen.
If there's a change
in cabin pressure
or there's a crisis
in the air, there's
going to be the little
yellow masks that
pop out of the ceiling.
Now, folks, those
are oxygen masks.
Now, don't start to ask, why is
my mask smaller than his mask?
Why is my mask
inconveniencing the meeting
that I'm supposed to hold?
No, grab the mask!
Put it on yourself first, and
then put it on your child.
Then if you have
more than one child,
you might want to stop to
consider which one really
has the most potential.
And that's what I want to
talk about here, because this
is how, when you
talked to Herb-- when
we did that interview, he
drank, I think, a full Scotch.
The bottle was empty by the
time we were talking two hours.
Didn't seem to affect him a bit.
He went through two
packs of cigarettes.
He was blowing it off screen.
He said, Mark, people do not
decide and choose explicitly
and intentionally to
live a life that matters.
We have to take a
moment and recalibrate.
We're not Nelson Mandela.
There's probably many
times during your life
where you redefine
what success means
and what that definition
of success is.
So let's look at
the factors that we
discovered in this research.
And one of them had
to do with the fact
that in a world that's
so volatile and changing,
we're all on this mission to
find a sense of belonging;
to create a life that matters.
And the primary
principle that seemed
to flow through all of these
came out of a research project,
as I mentioned.
And the project started
with "Built to Last."
I don't know if you ever
heard of "Built to Last."
It was one of those great
books, one of those many books
that was a bestseller,
and half of it was true.
And I had the opportunity
to be a part of the research
team at Stanford that was
working on this book--
part of that slave
labor that was doing
all of the conjoint analysis.
And Jerry Wind at
Wharton joined us,
Howard Moskowitz at Harvard.
Bonita Thompson
led the research.
She's a behavioral psychologist
who worked with Jim Collins.
And we then went on
a survey of people
who we thought had an
impact for 20 years or more.
In other words, the
cohort that we went after
were not people who were one-hit
wonders or short-term success
stories.
We're talking about
people who had impact
for at least two decades.
These were people who had been
living a life that matters.
And they might be celebrities,
they might not be.
Many of them were.
I did have a very
eclectic experience.
It started with Nelson Mandela.
I had the opportunity
to meet Maya Angelou.
I did many programs with her.
The Dalai Lama, met the
famous Googlers and the folks
at Microsoft from
the very early days.
It just shows how-- this
is going back to 1998,
when Larry bought YouTube
and was talking about that
at the forum--
into the present day.
And the adventure ended up
finding these criteria--
36 criteria in 2,000
interviews that we did.
And then we did a
survey in 110 nations
to try to force rank
what were these criteria
on the definition of success?
And what we found was that one
of the great core competencies
of people like yourself
who've achieved
is that you start
to work at putting
your demons in a place
where you can perhaps
harvest the energy from them.
It's a bit about mastering
fear and ambition.
Let me share with you a little
bit what I mean about that.
What we found was
that people who
have been able to find
a connection with a life
that matters tend to
be great at failure.
Winners lose often, and they
lose more often than losers,
because losers are
usually trying to avoid
the risk of making mistakes.
Winners-- people who have
impact year in and year out--
are usually experts at
learning, at iteration,
at being able to profit from
failure and from change.
And I don't know about
you guys, I often
feel this way in all of my work.
I always have way too much
more to do than I possibly can,
and short cuts never
apply when we do this.
So here's the first
principle at work.
We found that anyone
who had really
swung for the fences
in high achievement
had also failed
big time, and they
were experts at trying to
harvest their failures.
Let me give you
just one exercise
that we can all apply in how
we rethink any sort of disaster
that we've ever been in.
So Richard Branson, who was
one of the early sponsors
of this book, had
a tragedy occur
where he had been collecting
30 years of his notes
in the family home
on Necker Island,
and it burned down four
years ago, quite famously.
A bolt of lightning
came through the roof.
He'd been sleeping on
the beach, and the house
was filled with people.
And his 90-year-old
mom, Eve, was
able to escort, actually,
everybody out of the house
when this big
explosion occurred.
And she's still bragging
about it to this day--
Eve is.
And he said, I learned something
really profound that day.
Obviously, I was really worried
about people being hurt.
But then I realized how
helpless I was in that disaster.
I was down on the beach.
He was starting to
run to do the rescue,
and he realized he
wasn't fully clothed.
He was barefoot.
He ran straight into a cactus.
It wasn't a pleasant
experience for him.
And he realized something that
informed 30 years of his work
that had gone up in smoke,
and that is that if you did
want to restart a life or
a career or a business,
do you think you would do it
in exactly the same blueprint
that you had leading up
to that point of disaster?
In other words, one
of the greatest ways
to think about looking
forward in your life
is to restart the old life.
In other words, would you
have the same blueprint
for that house that you rebuild?
Would you have that same
work plan for your career,
or would you do
things differently?
Would you think about every
aspect or process of your work
or career in the same way?
I don't think so.
One of the best ways we can
think about our goal setting
every year is to say, what
if I were to start over?
What would I do differently?
How can I avoid just paving
the cowpath, as they say?
Would it be the same team?
Where is really, truly the value
creation in our life and work?
Think about that restart when
you're doing your goal setting,
rather than just thinking
about incrementing yourself
into the next thing you work on.
Now, I'm going to give you
some more tools to unpack this,
but I wanted to start
there, because a lot
of the work that we do and
a lot of the effort that we
put into the work that we do
ends up being through inertia.
And I hate this quote with
Edison talking about failure--
10,000 ways that it didn't work.
But the truth of the matter
is that when we make effort
and we are feeling like
we're having a setback
or we're humiliated from that
effort, the truth of the matter
is that people who are
continuing to have impact
continue to do that and
learn from that experience,
rather than allow
themselves to be weighed
under the pressures of it.
That whenever he
gets criticized,
he thinks about the
experience he has, like this--
Virgin, we have more experience
than our name would suggest.
That it's about iteration.
It's about the capacity to
be able to fail and move on.
The second principle that
we learn from this group
of high achievers--
like yourself-- was that--
is there anyone in this room
who has ever wanted
to do something
important in their
life or work where
others didn't approve of them?
Of course, we've all had or
continue to have-- constantly--
what we call the silent scream.
What is it in your life
or work that others
who love you, who
want to protect you
are trying to suppress, or would
hope that you'd make something
of yourself so that you'd
take another path in your life
and work?
This ends up being a very
common pattern for all of us,
and usually we tolerate it.
In fact, we end up fueling it,
because we do the second piece
of the silent scream.
The first piece ends up being--
we're allowing others to,
perhaps, deny that part
of our life that we care about.
And then secondly, we will
often hide that passion as well.
It's our secret.
It's what we don't want
other people to trash,
because it's
something that we love
and something that we treasure.
And then the irony of all
this is that, quite frankly,
people who love
you can see right
through the silent
scream, right?
The truth of the
matter is it loses out
around all the edges--
that when we do coaching with
high achievers like yourself,
we find all the time that there
is that silent scream that's
worth being aware of.
It's worth trying to
build a plan of safety
around that silent scream.
We're going to
talk more about how
to develop a safe way to
pursue your silent scream,
but here's a glimpse
at how we found
this cohort around the world,
in 110 nations, started
to deal with this.
We didn't find any person
who was doing something
extraordinarily well who didn't
have a portfolio of passions.
There isn't just one thing
to do with our lives.
Usually there was
a domain expertise
that was driven by an
obsession, but there was always
a portfolio of passions.
Other parts of that silent
scream that you tap--
that feeds you, that restore
you, that allow you to recover,
that allow you to become
resilient, that allow you to,
in a sense, create a more rich
and full life that matters.
There's an obsession,
I think, now,
with expertise and being
very precise about just
what one area that we focus on.
And what we found is
that people who've
had enduring lives of
creativity and contribution
have a silent scream
that contributes
to a portfolio of
passions, and it's
about putting a
spotlight on what
those are for you in your life.
The third area that
I found a bit ironic
is that people who
are high-achieving
have a paradoxical combination
of both hubris and humility.
Now, there was hubris,
you have to have--
people like my
friend Gail Devers.
She went to four Olympics.
Now, this woman, on the fourth
Olympic, got a gold medal,
and she lamented
the fact that she
hadn't broken the world record.
Seriously, Gail?
I mean, four Olympics?
And what we found was
that on the one hand,
she has this enormous
hubris to believe
that she can do so well at
something and the humility
to realize that I always
want to get better,
and that nothing
that I achieve can't
be done without and through
the efforts of others--
that it's a combination
of hubris and humility
that drives people
to have high impact.
We talked to Sally Field
early on in the interviews
that we were doing.
She's one of the
few women who've
worked for 40 years on stage
and screen, Emmy and Academy
Award-winning actress.
Started out in
meaningless roles,
ended up doing very meaningful,
high-contribution work.
Listen to how she
describes her journey.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The only thing
you have power over
is to get good at what you do.
That's all there is.
There ain't no more.
And the only time--
the only way you
become a leader--
or any such highfalutin
terminology--
a role model, a
leader, give back-- is
to have something to give back.
The only way you have
something to give back
is go do something.
Get off your rear end
and go do something.
And that doesn't mean I'm
going to go build housing
for the underprivileged.
That's good too, but
go become a doctor,
a lawyer, an Indian chief.
Go work your tail off
and achieve something
for yourself-- some
specific thing.
But be excellent
at what that is.
That's the only way that
you can be a leader.
Who wakes up one day and says,
hm, shall I go to school,
or shall I be a leader?
Let's see, what
shall I do today?
I think I'm going
to go out and lead.
- Nobody thinks that way.
- It's a non-thing.
It's a non-thing.
That happens by accident after
you've pursued and struggled
and kicked yourself around
the block 400 gazillion times,
and one day you look at it and
you say, OK, I've done that.
I've done that.
And people are turning to
you and saying, lead us.
Huh?
[END PLAYBACK]
MARK THOMPSON: On more
than one occasion,
I was delighted to
have been really put
in my place when I
asked questions like, so
how did you find that
leadership journey
as a woman on Hollywood?
And she said, are you nuts?
That's not how we go about
a journey that matters.
It's not about you.
It's about each of
us, individually,
finding that silent scream,
and reaching in and having
the humility and the hubris
to make choices about moving
towards that mission.
And if it's ever not a
struggle, then good for you.
But what the people who are
feeling their silent scream
feeding them ends up being
a very powerful combination
of hubris and humility.
I met Steve Jobs in high school.
I was a freshman.
He was a senior.
There was a summer at
Homestead High school
where we met each
other in a place--
well, I shouldn't
even tell you, but I
was in the principal's
office with him.
And I won't tell you why
we were there so long
or had such an
opportunity to bond,
but I will tell you that
it was interesting to hear
him talk about his dreams.
And at that time where I
was in my life, all that was
was frightening to me--
to hear his hubris and his sense
of ambition and creativity.
There's no way I was
going to chase him.
This is not a story of me
spending time in that garage
and becoming a billionaire.
There was no way
I could possibly
surrender, at that point, to
the seduction of what he already
had, which was clarity
about that silent scream.
Later, I would
have the privilege
of meeting him as
Steve 2.0, because
at that point in my career--
by 1999, I was chairman
of a company that
invented this little thing.
Anyone know what that is?
Yeah, Mp3 player.
Right, exactly.
I'm very proud of the fact that
while other technology has all
turned over in
the last 25 years,
nobody would think that it
would still be on your device,
but it's on pretty much
everybody's device today--
still, the Mp3
player, the audio.
I was chairman of that
little startup company,
and I was giving a
speech at Stanford,
and Steve Jobs was going
through his resurrection,
and he came up to the front.
He said, Mark, you're an idiot.
This is a geeky piece
of crap, and we're going
to crush it in about two years.
You want to come work for me?
What a recruiting.
This was Steve 2.0.
Don't let that attitude
ever be an excuse.
I don't know how many
leaders tell me, well, Steve
behaved that way.
I said, well,
there's an outlier.
Once we disrupt four
different industries,
then maybe we have
the privilege of being
that kind of personality.
But even he had started
to recognize that it
wasn't about him anymore.
He was going to have
to recruit A-players
from so many different
fields that it was always
about staying hungry and
staying foolish enough.
That this time he wasn't going
to lose his company again.
But it's interesting
to see-- and I say this
with the greatest
of love and respect,
because I had an
opportunity to work with him
over a three-year period.
He'd come a long
way as a leader,
but when you think about--
what was it, just
last week Apple
became the most valuable
company in the world?
Broke a trillion dollars.
They had already been the most
valuable company in the world,
but it wasn't until
2011 and his passing
that the company went
on to become the most
valuable in the world.
And it was interesting how
his transformation certainly
contributed to the
inertia in that company,
but he didn't turn all of
his wounds into wisdom.
This guy did.
Chuck Schwab-- being
fiercely independent,
having this hubris,
but then also being
set back by dyslexia.
When I met him, he talked
about how there was no way
that he could have built
a company if it hadn't
been by finding people who had
the strengths that he lacked.
And it turns out, at
Stanford Business School,
he ended up being one of the
people who most quickly scaled
a business out of
business school,
because he never thought he was
the smartest guy in the room.
He always chose to recruit a
team around him that could do
the things that he couldn't.
He put his life's work--
his silent scream--
turned it into passions,
and then instantly recruited
a team to that dream.
Who else could contribute
to that dream and those sets
of passions in ways
that they owned,
in ways that they could
make a unique contribution
of their own independent impact?
Listen to how Chuck
talks about this.
This is another
piece of archival.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- How'd do you go
about coping when you--
you went on to college
and started your career?
How did you get through college?
- I got through college
by a lot of luck,
and sometimes, I
think, even mirrors,
because I flunked English A
a couple times at Stanford,
and it was a very debilitating,
depressing thing for me
to do that, because I always
thought I was pretty bright,
and I didn't realize
how incompetent I
was in the skill of writing.
In some respects, the positive
side of this learning issue
thing was probably
my early recognition
that I wasn't strong in every
component of reading, writing,
all those kinds of things.
That I needed to have other
people who could help me out
in different parts of the
business that I was developing.
A lot of people
who are brilliant
will say-- who are
brilliant entrepreneurs--
think they can do everything.
And they don't develop
the team that they
need to have in order to
accomplish the various levels
that you're going to
reach in your growth
curve as a successful company.
And so at every level
that Schwab has moved to,
I've been able to,
I think, recognize
my strengths and my deficits
and build up around me
with great people
in the deficit area.
And I think that probably
has been the single most
important benefit
that I received
from having this learning
issue early on in my life.
So it's a little perverse
in some respects,
but at least that's the
way I rationalize it.
[END PLAYBACK]
MARK THOMPSON: One of the
best bosses I ever had.
Spent 12 years
working at his side.
Really informed
the way I decide.
Now, whenever I think about
what I want to do next,
I always think about who.
Don't just think
what, think who.
Think about the
community of people
who might share
that value, might
be able to contribute
to it in ways
that would be
profound for them as
well in their own
unique characteristics.
This works as well
in organizations
as it does with your
individual passions.
Always recruit a team to
that dream that you have.
And he did this in
such a beautiful way.
And with dyslexia, now,
he's one of the leaders
who was really changing the
way we think about learning.
He's got a wonderful foundation
called All Kinds of Minds,
finding geniuses everywhere
with every type of learning
that's out there.
I suffered a disability
early in my life--
an eyesight
disability-- which made
it profoundly difficult
for me to read
even up until middle school.
So whenever I'm introduced as
a "New York Times" bestselling
author, I always go, you
talking about me, David?
Because that was
always my struggle.
I could tell stories well,
but that eyesight issue
made it difficult with motor
skills and certain cognitive
processes until I got
through adolescence.
And it was one of the things
that called me to the work
that I do today in terms
of executive coaching,
because I always
felt that everyone
had their own form of genius.
That maybe they're A and
B-players, but truthfully,
it's more about A-alignment--
finding the things that we
are profoundly gifted at,
and be able to contribute that
with other people around us.
Turn your wounds into wisdom.
Principle number
five-- it's important,
and I'd love for you to ask
yourself this question, if you
could, today.
The people who have lives filled
with happiness and joy, people
who had lives that are
filled with meaning
take a moment each
day or each week
and shine a spotlight on who
and what in their life and work
is working.
And one of the
takeaways I'd love
for you to do when
you leave here today
is to think of
somebody to thank.
I've got Karen May here--
People Development
at Google-- who's
encouraged me to do
this work and encouraged
me to go around the world with
Googlers to think about this.
I have David, as
a dear friend now,
who's developed these
last couple of years.
You'll be getting a note.
I still have every note
that Chuck Schwab and Steve
Jobs ever wrote me.
I'll never throw that away.
Just think about the last note
that you wrote to somebody.
Write one.
Send that email.
It doesn't take that much
effort to thank someone,
and it makes a
profound difference
cognitively and emotionally
in how it touches you.
Some people call that gratitude,
but that sounds corny to me.
I'm really talking about who
and what works in your life.
It was really Richard
Branson, who's
continued to support this
work for my co-author,
Bonita Thompson, and my
daughter, who's a half-Googler.
The work that she did at
an internship here at 18
changed her life.
I want to thank
you guys at Google
for having such a profound
impact on my daughter,
because she's now a STEM major.
She went from being a
political science major,
which she was planning
to go to school--
she's now Berkeley math, and
she's pursuing a Haas degree
next, so thank you
for the contribution
you made to her life.
See how good that feels,
to be able to say something
like that?
The principle of having a
place that's safe to tinker
came up over and over
again at all 110 nations,
no matter who we
talked to as achievers.
There was always a safe
place for a garage.
And I call this a
garage, because if you
think about Silicon
Valley, we're
filled with garages
which don't have cars.
I don't know about you,
but when I was growing up,
I never visited a garage
that had a car in it.
What would you put a car--
unless you're inventing a car,
why would you put
a car in a garage?
This was a safe place to
tinker and create a new dream
or build something, or
do that craft project.
And you know, if it
wasn't good enough
to show the world, (WHISPERING)
nobody needed to know.
If it wasn't good enough
to leave the garage,
it didn't leave the garage.
And so what's interesting,
in organizations
and in the businesses that I've
helped build and in the lives
that I've helped support--
you need a place to tinker.
Where's your garage?
It's amazing.
Just across the Bay,
at Pixar, I work
with Jim Morris over there.
It's amazing to see how
they have safe places
to tinker on massively expensive
creative projects like films.
At Pixar-- as you know, if
you read Ed Catmull's book--
I think one of the very best
leadership books around--
and thinking about creating
a life that matters
is to read "Creativity, Inc."
Because he talks about that
place where you brainstorm,
and it's completely safe.
This is a brainstorming room.
And you never criticize
anybody's ideas
in that brainstorming room.
You plus it up.
You add to it.
If you're going to be
critical, you're out of there.
You've got to be able to build
on, on pile in a new way.
So where is your community, or
your mastermind for the dream
that you want to follow?
Is there a safe place to do that
and have people come and pile
on ideas?
And then, at least
at Pixar, they
realize they have
to run a business,
so then they take it
to another room to say,
OK, now we're going to
deconstruct the crime,
here, set priorities, which
are-- that's miserable.
I hate setting priorities!
No entrepreneur wants to decide
which goes and which stays
and what's done now
and what's done next.
And then they have
a third room where
they operationalize things.
That's the business school that
has to be practiced in order
to run a business.
So try to think about
a sense of place.
As humans, the
environment does win.
We do this at Google in terms
of having creative spaces.
But remember, if you could
have a place that you designate
that's safe to create, safe to
incubate, and safe to deliver,
that's really important.
We found it coming up
over and over again.
Another principle that
we found in this cohort
of high achievers
was that they--
like we talked earlier
about the silent scream--
anyone here have a secret
fear that they've run across?
We all have different
phobias and fears
that we've had to face.
Can I give you a
stupid one for me?
And it's pretty safe
to tell this crowd
about just having a fear of
heights and roller coasters.
I still, even to this day,
never been on a roller coaster--
not of any
consequence, at least.
And this was hard when I became
a daddy, because I would walk
my daughter to the
Matterhorn at Disney,
and I'd hear the
screams of delight,
and I heard her
screams of delight.
She looked like this
little one, here.
And we'd walk closer
and closer, I'd
be melting down and feeling
my hands getting sweaty,
and by the time we got just
up to deliver her and put her
on the ride, I'd say,
daddy's got to take a call.
Mommy's going to ride with you.
And that's what
we'd do every time.
She saw through
that very quickly.
Well, one of the things
that I'm embarrassed to
say that I didn't really
discover until this year--
an understanding in
this data that I've
been collecting for 20 years,
and it was around this idea
that often, people who are high
achievers-- they may or may not
face a fear down, but they
almost never think about it
as being a potential source of
joy if we could prepare for it.
What if there was some
way that we could somehow
prepare for this difficulty
in our life in a way
that there just might be
some shred of joy that
comes from it, that might
be an unlock for me?
And there ended up being one
for me in this particular case.
I decided that yes, OK, I was
going to be ambitious here.
I was going to toughen up.
I was going to face my fear.
I was going to take a
group of my clients.
It was the founder Pinterest,
the CEO of HP and the staff.
We rented a zero G
plane, and we went up
in the so-called vomit comet.
And what they do is
they rent 10 miles
by 100 miles of
the stratosphere,
and they do 15 parabolas.
And down you're doing
3Gs, and up you're doing--
well, zero G.
And it was some
macho thing in me
that said, oh, I
just have to do this.
Forget the roller
coasters or the skydiving.
I'm going to prepare for this.
Now, I'm 20 years older than
everybody who's on the plane,
so I trained
rigorously for this.
I started studying, why is
it that you get nauseous?
Mark, why do you get vertigo?
It's interesting, I'd
never leaned into my fear.
I'd never studied, what
do we know about people
who have fear of heights?
Why do I have this fear?
How could I address this fear?
I guess I could go to
therapy, but then that
would be just a cycle.
I wasn't really coaching myself.
I wasn't a very good student.
So I deconstructed this fear.
Now, I'm not saying
I conquered it.
I don't that's true.
I think what you do is
you actually manage it.
But I never thought
that I might harvest it.
So I ended up going
up in the vomit comet,
and I was thinking
this all along.
I was thinking about
the roller coaster ride.
I'm not going to be like
Ryan was in that movie.
But I was going to try to
find a way to go into zero G.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Perfect.
Look at me, Mark!
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Look at me!
[END PLAYBACK]
MARK THOMPSON:
Well, that was fun.
I would do that every
day of the week.
Something that apps--
that was doing something--
I can't imagine anything
more frightening than to deal
with looking out
into the stratosphere
and looking from dark to
light and plunging like that.
I stayed on the course.
I stayed very disciplined
about what they asked me to do,
but I never expected
to enjoy it.
What fears do we have in our
life that are holding us back
that there might be just
the shred of an unlock
that we are worthy of leaning
into and learning more about?
That's something I
never thought I would
explore for myself before.
And I would see it.
I observed it, and I've
been hearing people tell me
this for 20 years and
never internalized it
until this year-- or found
a way to exercise it.
You learn throughout life.
I'm hitting my
60th birthday here
and finding a new joy that I
missed for that last 60 years.
Now I'm feeling greedy.
What else have I missed
about what makes life special
and what makes life
so rich and creative?
And this is what is unique
about this cohort of people
that I found who
continue to re-evaluate
how to create a life that
matters and look at success.
So let's deconstruct that
one level further, here,
in the final piece.
I want to ask you folks--
if a loved one came to you not
knowing anything about what
you do for a living,
but they're loved ones.
Could be a child or a parent--
and asked you, what's your
definition of success?
What would you tell them--
just at the highest level?
What would be your
definition of success?
Anyone here, there's
no right answer.
Anyway, David, what would be
your definition of success?
DAVID: That the people I
love love me and are better
human beings because of it.
MARK THOMPSON: Is that a
lovely definition of success?
Give him a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
That's beautiful.
That's beautiful-- that the
community that I care about
is better off because
we're together,
and that you've contributed
to that community.
Anyone else?
What would be another
definition of success?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: A combination
of strong connections
with people in my life and
fulfillment in my career--
MARK THOMPSON: Fulfillment.
AUDIENCE: --and hobbies.
MARK THOMPSON: And being able
to do some of those passions
that, maybe, we talked about.
Maybe a fewer silent screams?
Give him a round of applause.
That's a great definition--
[APPLAUSE]
--that you could find, another
part of your life that you--
yes.
AUDIENCE: Happiness.
MARK THOMPSON: Happiness!
What a concept to
come with success?
And there would be dividends
of both of these others.
That's a great definition.
Give her a round of applause.
Success.
[APPLAUSE]
Any other definitions
of success?
Anything else that
comes to mind?
She was doing her hair back
there, so you won the bid.
What would be your definition?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
not my definition,
but a definition associated
with the probability
of wealth, fame, prestige.
MARK THOMPSON: Yes, exactly.
So this is an interesting
point that we'll make.
So if you looked up the
definition of success
in the dictionary,
which actually
didn't occur to me
to do 20 years ago
when we started the research.
But our Wharton team
said, we're going
to publish this book
with Prentice Hall.
We got to do the research.
Look in the dictionary!
That was the definition
in the dictionary.
But that's it.
The definition that
we heard from people
who had high impact
in their lives
and had developed lives
that truly mattered for them
and others didn't have
wealth, fame, or goals
actually on the list.
So what we teach our kids
or feel conflicted about--
one of the reasons the silent
scream is so profound--
is because we have
a double standard
on how we define success--
in every language, by the way.
If you can find another one,
I'll send you a nice bonus.
If you can find a way that
the definition of success
is defined anywhere else.
It's a punishing, evil
definition of success,
frankly, because it's
not how successful people
who've had lives that
matter long periods of time
define success.
In fact, the
definition of success--
I shouldn't be surprised,
and I hear this at Google,
wherever I go in the
world, and I've now
asked people live
and in meetings
like this, 15,000 people.
They define success the same
way that you did in this room.
And it ends up being
characterized this way.
And the thing I want
to say about this
is also for you to
notice you should never
assume that you know somebody's
definition of success.
There's more than
one definition.
I'm not sure that your
definition of success
might have been the same
even five years ago.
But check in to find out what a
person's definition of success
is.
You might be profoundly
touched by how they frame it.
Knowing that about
David, or knowing
that about how you sense this
connection with your passions
makes a difference
in your relationship
with that person-- how
they define that success.
There's not just
one way to do it.
What we found was that
there's three categories
of the definition of success.
All three of these were
present in everyone
who had had impact
for 20 years or more.
They had a sense of purpose
or a cause-- something
that they were associated
with that was greater
than themselves, but
that they believed in;
that they cared about.
They had a sense of
passions and connection.
They had a sense
of who they wanted
to be with through
their purpose,
but also through their hobbies
and through their passions
and through the work
that they wanted to do.
And then they also had a
way of actually wanting
to deliver on the goods.
I mean, it's one thing
to be purpose-driven,
but it's hard to
really earn the right
to do that unless
you can deliver
on some of your promises.
But this was what we'd
call the genius of the end,
rather than the
tyranny of the OR--
that when you're
feeling out of balance,
it's not just because you can't
do enough of the one thing
that you love.
It's because we're
often not doing things
that we can see connected
to something bigger than us
or a community bigger
than us and that
also feeds our passions.
The passions are about
things that we do on our own.
They're not about winning.
They're about doing
something we believe in,
that we want to refine.
It's something that we
want to be a part of.
Performance has to
do with our ability
to deliver on those things.
And what I'd love
to do right now
is just serve you a set of
definitions around passion
so you can mine this
a little deeper.
So what we found is
that there are really
six dimensions of passion.
And the reason I have Maya
Angelou and Warren Buffett
up here is because when I
went to visit Maya Angelou,
she talked about how most of
us don't live our lives feeling
all three of these.
That it's easy to maybe focus
on one but not the other two.
That when we're
feeling out of balance,
it's because we haven't
decided wait, OK,
so how is this connected
to something bigger than me
or longer-term?
Some people might even
call this a legacy.
And this could be a community.
It doesn't have to--
it could be a company.
It could be a customer--
just something
bigger than ourselves.
Passions are for you.
Performance is how we deliver
and express all of those.
So let's go through purpose,
passion, and performance.
But one thing about
Warren Buffett--
Warren Buffett won't accept a
job inquiry from an individual
unless they qualify
for all three of these.
He says a lot of
people will have
a sense of how they've served
a business or a purpose
in the past.
They'll express, maybe,
how they've delivered
in terms of performance.
But when it comes to
passion, most people
put that off and don't integrate
that in with their work.
That passion is not
something you should put off
to another time, It needs to be
a part of your everyday work.
He said to put off your passions
is a little bit like saving up
sex for old age.
It's a really bad idea.
We should be living
full-out, right now.
I said, good for you, Warren.
I want to be that way
when I'm 80, right?
The Oracle of Omaha says that
we should be living full-out,
and so does the poet, as
she expresses her life.
So let's look
quickly at passion.
Passion, we found--
this portfolio
of passions we
talked about-- you
can look at this set of
passions in the sense
that one of the ways to evaluate
whether you're doing something
you're passionate about is that
you will lose sense of time.
[INAUDIBLE],, the
social scientist,
would call experts
of their field,
whether they were
artists or chemists,
and say, how long have you
been working on the project?
Don't look at a watch.
They could never say.
Your unconscious
competence-- you'll
lose that when
you're in the flow.
Ever been in the flow?
You're doing
something else, and it
starts to contribute to
answering the question.
As soon as you let
go of the problem--
you're running,
you're reading, you're
doing your favorite knitting--
then it starts to flow for you.
So when you watch
the flow, that's
usually an indication
of passion.
We tend to have a bias when
it comes to defining failure.
That generally, when
you're doing something
you're passionate about,
it's not a failure.
It's a learning.
We redefine it.
I used to run and play
music in high school.
I don't run anymore, because
I wasn't that good at it,
so I failed at that.
But I'm still playing
the horn, even though I
wasn't very good at it.
But I'm learning.
I'm getting better and better.
I'm still trying to
be creative that way.
We tend to be proactive
and do the things
we're passionate about first.
We like to think
we're objective,
but we have decision bias.
The things that get
at the top of the list
are generally the ones that we
feel the most passionate about.
I'm geeking over this.
Because I'm not a
behavioral psychologist,
I really wanted to look at
how the behavioral data--
when we did a forced ranking
and we asked people in this
conjoint analysis to determine
what they really cared about--
these were the
dimensions of passion.
That passion is something
you'd secretly do for free.
Now, I know Google
is a business,
but we're all hopefully driven
not just by the clock, right?
We're driven with
doing something--
some aspect of the day.
I mean, life is short, but
some days are very long, right?
Not everything we do
is something we love,
and it's not what I'm
really proselytizing here.
What I'm saying is
that there needs
to be some aspect of the work
we do that feeds us, even
without traditional
compensation.
You bore people when
you're passionate.
So you go to a party, and
if somebody asks me about
my daughter-- please
don't make this mistake--
I will not shut up.
You'll be looking at me, saying,
I'm so happy for you, Mark.
They're looking at their watch.
They feel the aging process.
They don't know how to get
out of the conversation.
Mark is still geeking over it.
You're not politically correct
or socially conscious--
entirely-- when you're
in a state of passion,
when you're living your passion.
Now, this is an important way
to deconstruct relationships,
because it's good to know what's
flipping somebody's switch
so that you can either
feed that for them
or help align them
with that on a project
or help associate with them
if you share that passion.
This is another dimension of it.
You definitely bore
people when you're
passionate about something.
And it's also something
that you would hope that,
in history, that you'd
like to be remembered for.
It usually is the
thing that, gosh, I'd
love to say that the passions
that I've been living
and the purpose I'm feeling
could somehow be remembered;
that somehow would be a part of
my legacy, that could somehow
maybe make a difference, and it
would make a life worth living.
I do spend some considerable
time up at Nike,
and what's the slogan at
Nike that's most famous?
AUDIENCE: Just do it.
MARK THOMPSON: Wouldn't you
love to have a slogan like that?
Everybody, in any language, it
always comes back "Just do it"
in English.
Why is that so compelling?
Cuts through the clutter and
the bullshit of our lives
and the pressure
and the denial that
comes from other people about
what we really want to do.
We just want to do it, but we
don't want to just do anything.
We want to do
something that matters.
I love the current positioning
that they have right now.
They talk about trying to find
your inner athlete, whether you
are an athlete or not, and
to play to be remembered.
I think what we'd
all love to feel
is that somehow the
impact and the creativity
and the meaning that
we found in our life
would mean that we had
played to be remembered.
That we were writing
our own future.
That would be, perhaps,
the most profound way
to think about our lives.
I'd like you all to just
stand up for a moment.
I asked you the
definition of success,
and I just want to make a
closing request of you all,
and then we'll do some Q&A.
I asked you, a moment ago,
your definition of success.
And you were processing
this and hoping
I wasn't going to call
on you, and as you
were doing that, I'd
like to now invite
you to think about the fact
that the success that you've
achieved is not entirely yours.
It's also because there's
a contribution from others.
That there's other
people in your life
and your work that have
helped make you successful.
Isn't that right?
It's not just about you.
So could you try to
picture in your mind,
for a moment, someone
in your life or work
who's somehow contributing
to the success
that you've enjoyed
in your life?
Can you get that
picture in your mind?
If that person was
trying, somehow,
to get through Google security
and was being arrested
at the front door,
do you think you
could make a noise so loud
to alert them all that they
should let he or she in?
Do you think you could make
a noise so loud in this room
that you could indicate how
much you love this person?
1, 2, 3, and then
on the count of 3,
you're going to give
me a noise so loud
that you're going to have
them released from security.
1, 2, 3, go!
[SCREAM]
OK, very nice.
Please sit down.
That's great.
They're letting
them through now.
Could you check on that, Mitch?
Yeah.
I wish I had had somebody
there this morning
when I was trying to get in.
The reason I did that is
because there are so few times
in our life and
work that we really
show that level of
gratitude to the people that
mean the most to us.
Would you promise me one thing?
That when you leave
here today, that you
could let those few
people who qualified
for you at that
mental list of success
know that you gave
them a shout-out today,
as corny as that may be?
That'll make your day better.
That'll make you feel
profoundly better,
and it's what the most
creative, high-impact people do.
Thank you so much.
I'd love to take questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, Mark.
Thanks.
So yeah, there's
the three P's, and I
feel like certain ones come
easier to me than others, and--
MARK THOMPSON: Damn straight.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So--
MARK THOMPSON: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: --getting stuff
done or performance, sure.
But there's the passion
and then there's the--
MARK THOMPSON: Purpose.
AUDIENCE: Purpose, oh yeah.
So the purpose one--
I can think through it,
but it's not natural.
How does it come to you?
Is it really a thought process,
or it's really centering
and comes from the heart?
Have you heard of people
struggling with that?
MARK THOMPSON: Yes,
absolutely, and I
think we have to reaffirm
what we believe in
and re-evaluate that, probably,
at many different points
in our life and in our career.
What we found is that the
process that many people go
through is to try to get a sense
of what their purpose might be
by looking at their career
over time and seeing,
what are the proudest
moments that you have?
In your personal life, what
were the proudest moments
that you had?
What were the ones that give you
the most energy on reflection?
Lay it out in a timeline.
And one of the ways that
you can observe that list
is to start to deconstruct,
what'd be the three or five
reasons, in terms of purpose of
that work that you were doing--
frame it that way--
that it gave you that response?
Let's start with what
gives you a sense of pride.
Now, I'm grossly oversimplifying
a much deeper process
that we can talk about,
but the idea is to say,
are those areas of
your life that you're
the proudest about feeding a
sense of purpose in any way?
They may also be feeding
a sense of passion
and some of the
things that you'd just
like to do for your own sake,
and it helps separate it
from a moment from achievement,
because usually when
you answer this question
of proud of most moments,
you probably already tick
the box for performance.
We're-- especially
Western society--
very much trained towards
outcomes and achievement,
and we're programmed for that.
That's part of
the silent scream.
If there's something
that we love
that's not achievement-oriented,
that's probably
in the silent scream category.
It's one of those hard
things to resurrect
into your active portfolio
of passions that you have.
AUDIENCE: It's very easy to
define success, looking back.
So, I don't know,
if Larry started out
with the mission of
organizing the world's
information or Zuckerberg
started out with organizing--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK THOMPSON: The revisionist
history of the past, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So looking forward, how do
you define your mission,
or how do you know what
you are passionate about?
Because honestly, I
don't know what I am
passionate about at this point.
MARK THOMPSON: You know, it's
because of a lot of inertia
that we often lose
track of what we feel
that we're most
passionate about,
which is why I would love to--
I can send to you-- and you'll
also find it in the book,
or if you didn't get
a copy of the book,
we can send that to you.
I'd be happy to send that free--
the criteria around
passion, because you
can explore some of those
areas that speak to you;
those areas that you
find that you are talking
about a little bit too
long with a loved one,
the category of areas where
you find yourself spending time
when you're not working.
Is there something you're
naturally being gravitated to?
What are those areas
that you are not
putting a spotlight on
now because they're not
achievement-oriented
or outcome-oriented?
Is there anything
that you particularly
look forward to in the work
that you're doing right now?
What aspect of it do you hate?
What aspect do you
love about that?
I often go through
a process where
it's more interesting to
look at what you hate and see
why you hate it.
And you think, that's
a really dumb idea.
Why would we look at the things
that we consider a failure
and hate the most?
Because what's
shocking is if you
share that with
three other people,
they may not agree with you
as that's the worst thing that
ever happened to them.
What's so shocking in the work
that I do among high achievers
is that I'll just assume that
the things that people love
are this and that things
that they hate are that,
and I'm wrong every single time.
A person might say,
gosh, well, what
I hate about this is that nobody
knows that I did the work,
and I'm not getting recognition.
And so I don't feel
significant here
unless I have a speaking part.
And the next person over,
who's a high achiever,
will say, what I
hate most about this
is I have to get up every
time and speak about this.
I can't stand being
in front of a crowd.
So to deconstruct what it
is that you hate so much--
I call this ballast.
If you were to look at the
high points in your life--
the proudest moments--
and the worst
moments in your life
and just spend an
extra moment looking
at why you hate the things
you hate, if you flip that
into energy, if you flip that
into why it's holding you down,
you'll get the
insight into something
that could be really
miraculous in your life.
So my wife, who's my co-author
on all of this work--
her brother died when he was 21.
He was already
taken-- he was already
bicycling over to NASA--
a savant, a genius.
And you might ask three people--
obviously, the loss of
a brother when you're 18
and he's 21 particularly
would be so profoundly
impacting your life.
And you'll almost find as
many reasons in this room
why that's a bad thing as
there are people in this room.
But for her, the greatest loss
was the lack of contribution
that he would have.
The world lost a genius.
That's probably not the
first thing the next three
people would say.
So what did that do to inform
what she cherishes and believes
in?
I'm going to spend my life--
I realized that's
what I care about.
I'm projecting it on all
the other important people
in my life.
So she spends her
life trying to create
a life that matters for others.
For me, I was held back because
of a developmental disability.
I never, now, assume a person's
intelligence or capacity
until we actually work
together to try to unlock what
that is, because everybody
has a certain form of genius.
And the most key
part of innovation
is to try to unlock
that particular genius.
I have endless
patience for that,
because if I didn't, I
wouldn't believe in myself.
It's a personal projection
of that passion.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thank you for this
very inspirational talk.
So the common
definition of success
is money, fortune, fame,
power, and all that,
and I can tell
from your talk you
and your friends probably
enjoyed a lot of that.
But meanwhile--
MARK THOMPSON: No,
we're all losers.
We're just--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
but Meanwhile, do
you agree that a majority of
people just don't have those?
Majority of people are
just common people?
MARK THOMPSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: My son also
goes to Homestead High,
and I try to inspire him.
Hey, look at Steve Jobs.
He was so great, [INAUDIBLE].
He said, dad, he was
just an exception.
I'm a normal kid.
MARK THOMPSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And that makes sense.
So--
MARK THOMPSON: It's
a fair point, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Do you think that,
for common people,
it's also important to find
that satisfaction and content
from just doing normal things?
MARK THOMPSON: Yes!
AUDIENCE: Just be
content with what we got?
MARK THOMPSON: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Just for a
paying job at Google--
MARK THOMPSON: If
that's what you value.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Yeah, you're definitely
a very normal,
under-privileged Googler.
[LAUGHTER]
Because that sets the
bar a certain place
that is maybe, a
little, also privileged.
The point of all this
really is that it's
for each and every one of us to
find our purpose, our passion,
and performance.
The only reason I use
the famous examples is
because you know them
and because I was shocked
at how inadequate each and every
one of them were to the task
that they were faced with.
And yes, maybe they are the
long tail or the unicorn,
but each and every one
of us are a unicorn.
Really, what we should be
looking at-- the standard that
we were setting, the standard
that you're setting at Google
for your son--
is that he live a
life that matters--
to him.
Nobody else can make
that decision for him.
And that's the silent scream.
So your job is to say--
not to talk about Steve
Jobs, because he's actually
a terrible role model--
is to talk about what's
so special about him
that he lays up at
night thinking about,
that he's afraid to
talk to you about,
that you could empower so
he could be lighting up
the sky with that work.
It may not be
politically correct.
He may not become a
doctor or a lawyer.
But he might end up
being the best creator.
He might be the best inventor.
What could you feed--
Jane Goodall would
lose the daughter.
She was four years old.
She'd wander off, and she'd
look for hours for her daughter,
and her daughter
would be found there
and she was looking
at the lizards.
She was looking at the bugs.
Well, that wasn't a
politically correct profession
in a family that had
all doctors and lawyers,
and she became Jane Goodall.
So there's a shred of a place
of joy and contribution,
and that's what we, as parents,
are so challenged to find.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There was
a quote earlier--
something about winners
and losers, and winners
lose more than losers.
MARK THOMPSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
how would you define losers?
MARK THOMPSON: Yeah,
no, it's not a fair--
I'm glad you pointed
it out, because I'd
be supremely disappointed if
I didn't get called on that,
so thank you.
Give her a big
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So if there's any
great exception,
I think, to the way
this is presented,
you'd never talk about
winners and losers.
The reason I did that, though,
is for a very specific reason.
And that is that if you
talk to people who--
if you didn't know
that they had had
some celebrity or
additional success,
you'd find that they
spent more airtime talking
on their failures than
on their successes,
that they were learning from
iterating towards an outcome
that they were seeking.
The point I was really
trying to make there
is that we fail more
often than we succeed
if we're really trying hard
at something we care about,
and that's OK.
In fact, that's the only way
to fail forward to success.
Usually 10 times
more losses than wins
for people who are trying
to do something meaningful.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you feel like you
don't have a silent scream, is
it better to A, hope it comes
organically, B, cultivate one
that you want to have, or
C, just give up on the idea
that you'll matter?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK THOMPSON: It sounds like
a standard Google bubble test.
Isn't there a D?
All of the above, or
none of the above?
It doesn't have to be
so much a silent scream.
I mean, the good news might
be, do you enjoy your work?
AUDIENCE: Moderately.
MARK THOMPSON: Moderately.
AUDIENCE: I enjoy
everything moderately,
so there's nothing
that's a peak or a low.
MARK THOMPSON: OK,
so it's a matter
of starting to notice whether
there's peaks or lows,
starting to notice the things
that really irritate you
the most, because there might
be the germ of something you
really care about there.
So I have good
friends who are just
offended if they see bad code.
I have friends who are offended
if they see a bad ad written.
These are insights
into-- maybe she
should be spending some more
time doing copywriting on ads.
And that's not something
you've ever been offered
in your life, most likely.
It's so amazing to me,
being a late parent
and having my daughter go to
a great school like Berkeley,
but it's interesting asking the
kids, what do you want to do
and why do you keep
changing your mind?
It's because, dad, we
never got asked a choice.
We were never offered
an opportunity
to test new ideas out, right?
That's not what you're
really allowed to do.
Pass the AP test, right?
Get the performance done.
So things do end up
getting mediocre.
I like everything
moderately well,
because I did get
A's in those classes.
But you really haven't been
offered this opportunity, now,
to step back for a moment
and look at the things that
are your highs and your lows.
You'll start to
see some of them.
And if you do some more reading
about "The Passion Test,"
you're going to find
that some of those areas
do activate you
more than others.
Some you're better at.
Some of those speak to you more.
And that that might be a
way to start to find a way
to lean into those ideas.
Thank you, everybody.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]